un village de gillet jeunes à l'entrée
de la zone industrielle démarré à
coignières des citoyens avec des
situations sociales différentes tous
mobilisés contre la politique du
gouvernement
nous on commence à prendre racine il ya
une chose qui a apporté ce mouvement et
et indirectement le président c'est une
solidarité
il a réussi à voile a rassemblé quand
même pas mal de monde et on commence à
se créer une petite famille gilet jaune
et de ceux qui soutiennent à travers un
barrage filtrant les gie les jeunes
s'organisent pour faire vivre leur
mobilisation ce matin des élus de
coignières sont venus leur rendre visite
après l'installation d'une benne à
ordures par les services municipaux pour
voir quelles sont les quels sont les
besoins fait faire en sorte avant tout
que ça se passe bien aussi bien pour eux
que pour les automobilistes qui passent
s'il ya une volonté de donner la parole
aux français aux citoyens par
l'intermédiaire des mairies on le fera
enfin c est ça me paraît une évidence
augmentation de 100 euros du smic prime
d'activité comprise défiscalisation des
heures supplémentaires ou suppression de
la hausse de la csg pour les retraites
inférieures à 2000 euros
les mesures annoncées par emmanuel
macron est jugée insuffisante
beaucoup de personnes ici que je veux
que j'ai rencontré le monde bien fait
comprendre que voilà c'est ça suffit pas
ça suffit pas nous ce qu'on veut c'est
pouvoir d'achat voilà c'est juste vivre
j'ai entendu c'est un premier pas qui
est intéressant maintenant il ya
tellement tellement tellement tellement
tellement de choses qui n'ont pas été
abordés qu'au final en fait c'est du
vent je le prends comme ça sert que
quand on quand on est sur une
intervention médicale et qu' il ya une
hémorragie on met pas un pansement
on sort les gros moyens et on sauve la
personne cj les jeunes ont prévenu ils
sont prêts à passer les fêtes ici en
famille à l'entrée de la zone
industrielle des marais de coignières